hey guys how's going terrico this year
onset for fighting weights and just have
a little bit of fun on one of the ropes
here someone used to do as a kid
luckily I'm still able to do that for a
variety of reasons obviously making the
Fitness have kept that part of my life -
the most part of my life there was a
little time in there when that rut
wasn't really so important so when I was
a kid I used to play all sorts of sports
I played soccer for probably nine years
I also played golf for several years and
when you're playing golf not doing much
else and you're eating Grandy's which is
one of my favorite restaurants back then
hash brown bacon egg and cheese biscuit
and a 32-ounce dr. pepper for breakfast
every morning it tends to put a little
bit of weight on you and it was around
that time - I had been I started racing
cars my number one passion when I was
about 15 and my dad one day said you
know if you'd put as much effort in
yourself as you do your cars you'd go
somewhere and couldn't really argue with
that point and when you're racing cars
every pound is precious I mean it's
tenths of a second on a road course so I
decided you know what he's right I need
to do something about this and so I did
and I remember weighing myself on day
one when I started this it was I think
197 pounds and after about nine months
worth of sticking to that diet and
working out six days a week I went down
to 141 today I'm about 162 162 this is
where my body's happy I'm right around
nine or ten percent body fat so you know
I'm not a world-class athlete but then
again that's not the point so when I'm
back home my typical week looks
something like this I try to work out
five days a week at least
and I'll vary it I'll jump on my bike
and go for a you know 1518 mile bike
ride I live out by the beach which is
cool so we've got some rings and some
ropes like gymnastics type stuff that
I'll go out there and I don't look the
prettiest doing it but it's a lot of fun
it's a really good workout so that's my
tip I guess keep it fun find things you
really like to do that keep you in shape
and do them so we got a lot more of
those tips a lot more workouts coming
your way from fighting weight right here
at our new studio so you guys make sure
to subscribe to the channel we'll see
you guys soon
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
other fighting weight episodes
you